hey slow start little acres offense away
and beat from deep smokes the net and
he's got five four two and assist they
got four assists on five basket so far
and being a great dick to dogs for
Simmons early on McConnell on him ball
no points so far in the game and B sends
it back with one on a timer right
through the double team is coming 'tony
are good for covington jumping much more
including gave one of our NBA Wednesday
doubleheader between Cleveland Charlotte
and B from Simmons and at me now with 15
points
Simmons beautiful dish - and being a
three-point play pump up the handle MERS
by Simmons and then the pass to him beat
he's got to play better
[Music]
and B blocks Lopez and again runs the
floor and B great pass Simmons what the
monster stop table shows and in
Philadelphia with those incredible fans
impede wow what a play by MB making sure
he didn't charge into Lopez great feet
17 points and eight rebounds for Ingram
we talked so much about a young talent
on Philly
Zen beat scores again now question
Randall on the drive block by him be
Simmons on the smaller caldwell-pope
here comes a triple team and now and
beat for three or two of three from
three and 10 of 12 at the line for MB
and a great pass to Simmons assist
number six for MV 14 points for Simmons
[Music]
[Applause]
and beads facing up on Randall he'll
take the jumper and knock it down to
give him 36 points on 15 shots and big
goes at Randall in scores he's got 39
Lakers have scored nine and last 12
points to retake the lead
MV Dillon work counted in a foul
41 friend P holds for a five-game stand
in Philadelphia after tonight it's
Redick from MPD counted seven assists
brandied and the lead is eight and B
Drive scores 46 Granby